THIS IS THE FIRST
EVER MEETING
BETWEEN THESE TWO
FRANCHISESSTICKS IT
LANE.
BUT MARCHAND WASN'T
THERE.
ONE IS RIGHT HERE
OFF THE RUSH.
THROWS IT BACK TO
THE PERIMETER.
BLACKWELL HIS FIRST
TOUCH.
AND
PASTERNAK CAN'T
THROW ITITWHO BREAK
TO MARCHAND. JUST R
>> WHAT IS THE
PLAYER ONE TOUCH.E
NEUTRAL ZONE AND I
CAN'T GET IT PASSED
----
LEG.
THOUGHT HE WAS
GOING TO GET
MAN-TO-MAN
ADVANTAGE.E. A
BACKEND ATTEMPT
ACROSS THE ICE BY
THEIR TOTAL
OFFENSE.
>> Andy: YOU PLAY.
PANEL. NOSEK SPINS
HAYDN FLEURY.  ING
LINE SET UP
POSITION TONIGHT.
LOTS OF POOR
BATTLES HERE LATE
WE ARE GOING TO
SHOW YOU THE . STRO
STICK FROM HALL.
IT WAS SCORED BY
JERSEYS AROUND THE
PUCK.
MASONB APPLETON N K
APPLETON GETS A
PIEC
PASTRNAK INTO
THE NET.
GOOD KEEP IN BY
McAVOY.
AND THE QUICKNESS.S
BALLS ARE NOSEK.